hello we are really honored to present  the Award for Best Song in a motion  picture songs have a magical power to  transport us to a different time and  place there's no greater weapon in a  director's arsenal than a strategically  placed song but there's one song that  nobody wants to hear the song they play  when your acceptance speech has gone on  too long that's the song that won and  did you know it actually has lyrics this  is it your time is through your boring  you're rambling on no end in sight  you're boring no need to thank your  parakeets you're boring  Catherine Zita Joe she's snoring  you could have rushed up to the stage  but you were lollygagging  and turning off your microphones and  casting to a commercial  Oh  Oh  you